all right it's my turn to take over
hello everyone and welcome to the game
squad stage here at e3 2016 I'm Lucy
James joined here by a couple of
excellent guests we've got Justin hey
Walt howdy howdy
and Aaron Greenberg from Xbox good to be
here so you guys had an incredible press
conference yesterday what is this he
brought I brought I figured you know we
should do more than just show you a
video what if we actually brought the
real thing so yeah we had a great
conference I think it's awesome to be
able to announce new hardware very rare
you get to announce two new consoles and
one briefing and so we opened it up with
the Xbox one s which is available at
this August and it is a 40% smaller Xbox
one and also has the power supply
built-in comes with a new controller
that has Bluetooth included and for
people to have 4k TVs it does 4k video
streaming it also plays 4k blu-rays and
will play your games in HDR and so
really really a lot of great
advancements for people that are looking
to upgrade the solid a do you know how
many teraflops are they we have broken
into teraflop so yes well it's funny you
mentioned teraflops because we also
announced project Scorpio which is
coming next holiday and with that really
the idea was what if we went off and
built the most powerful console ever
made and could deliver true 4k games
these native 4k games things we've never
seen in consoles before and those that
actually does require six teraflops of
power so we're excited to build a beast
of a box with six teraflops of power be
able to bring true 4k games also that
enables us to do things like high
fidelity VR and I think a lot of the
experiences that people that have like
super high-end PC rigs and things like
that may have been experiencing but to
be able to bring that to the living room
with the console next year we're really
excited to have that happening as well
so I was actually really curious about
announcing a console like that of course
the Xbox 1s seems like it's a very smart
move but it feels like it can be a
little bit risky to announce a new more
powerful system with
the specs without a release date and
knowing that it's going to be in the
future is there any fear that maybe
that'll cannibalize sales of the the
current Xbox or the s yeah we gave it a
lot of thought I mean first we really
wanted to be thoughtful about what is
that next change where it made sense to
iterate with hardware for us reducing
size is really important we know a lot
of people are adopting 4k TVs to build
or bring all those benefits and HDR but
this box made sense but the leap to true
4k gaming and the power of project
scorpio is a pretty big jump from where
we are today in the console market and
so that's why we wanted to announce it
now because we want to let our
development partners be aware of it when
people that are making those great game
experiences today to say listen we're
gonna extend the limits of your
imagination of what you're creating and
so to be able to unlock that and deliver
you know true 4k games which you can
just imagine how big those games will be
it's something we're super excited about
and frankly as a you know as for
consumers now they know they have the
great option this holiday with a great
value in a great box or if they want to
wait and get something that is optimized
for even more power next year they have
that choice we still have a lot of
people believe it or not that are still
tens and millions of people still on
Xbox 360 that haven't upgraded so if
they're waiting we think this is a great
great time to upgrade as well are there
gonna be exclusive games that just work
on scope yeah a lot of people have asked
that so the big vision for us is that we
want to be able to allow everything just
to work your games your Xbox one console
games to work your accessories to work
so if you buy games today they will be
for compatible as well so and as part of
that we're not making Scorpio exclusive
console games obviously we do something
there with some high fidelity VR that
would be different but for console games
we want to be able to do is one plan for
that now for people that are building
games now like the team that's working
on Gears of War for you know they know
Scorpio is coming so there's some things
they can do in Gears or for this holiday
that will make sure it takes advantage
of the power of Scorpio and that comes
out a year later and then of course when
you know we look at the lineup of games
that will be coming you know another
year from now that can take advantage of
the true
of a native 4k box and I think another
really exciting thing that came out of
the press conference was the play
anywhere program like for me as a PC
gamer who who does console gaming but my
primary place is the PC that's really
exciting yeah I mean for us you know
you've heard Phil Spencer talk a lot
about we always want to put the gamer at
the center of everything we do and it's
one thing to say that but we really
thought like what if we could actually
take the games you own and allow you to
give you more value where you buy games
from us digitally but you can play them
both on Xbox one and on Windows 10 and
we know that gamers don't just play
their games in the living room on the
console they continue to play those
games on other devices many PC gamers
out there weren't experiencing our game
so to be able to bring those titles to
both and allow you to download them on
your Windows 10 PC and play them on your
Xbox one and have full compatibility for
both your accessories to work all that
was a big part of the vision all right
Aaron this is killing me can we see
what's in the box please yes let me let
me do this very very carefully it's all
of your heads right you're just gonna
blow how funny you mentioned I have some
airhead bites would you mind if I had an
airhead bite before I did this unboxing
okay you know it was a really energy to
get through this we do I do need a
little energy you know because sometimes
you want an airhead and sometimes you
just want an airhead bite okay there we
go mmm those are actually very good okay
so tightly packed box we're pretty
committed to that this is where things
that come with your console go um okay
maybe the airhead bite before the
unboxing wasn't the right idea so first
thing you'll notice is I'm holding this
with one hand
hable you can't do that today I think I
can hold an Xbox with one hand you say I
don't maybe you're in a different little
bit down the gym I absolutely cannot
look at look at Lucy's biceps that's
well now we all can spit it out no no I
know it's actually very good I'm
enjoying it um but I don't want to delay
what people are gonna experience here so
let me set this down here let me let me
hold it for a second so you can already
tell forty percent smaller if you're
thinking jump it
it's okay we have more um yeah I gonna
have this one day so the binding of
controllers is now on the front yeah ir
blaster in the front this is the actual
power button and then you can do it both
horizontal and vertically so if you
stand it up in fact you'll see that it
we've already got the Xbox logo here
ready for you it felt like more of a
more of a button press mm-hmm this time
on the on button because I know that I
can I can brush past my xbox one nail
right my brush past my xbox it turns on
which having a cat is the worst as well
yes so pushing button and then if people
want to see you can see all the ports
here in the back so we have both HDMI
out and HDMI in for a lot of people I'll
use watch my TV my xbox one more USB
ports optical audio Ethernet in addition
to of course Wireless and get a sense of
the size so how does connect work with
that it doesn't look like there's the
dedicated connect correct so we have a
free adapter that anybody that has a
connect that wants to use it we have a
free adapter that we provide that allows
you to continue to use connect with this
box as well and then we'll first stop
for should a controller this is it this
is the power cord no more brick no more
brick which I think it's great and then
new controller which is very very
similar to the existing controller which
you know our gamers love a little bit
more texture here on the handles in
there and then Bluetooth built in so
again just like your games with Xbox
play anywhere you can also take your
controller from your console to your PC
we use the proprietary wireless for
speed on the console but with Bluetooth
that works great on your on a Windows 10
PC as well yeah and so this starts at
$2.99 it comes out in August we also
have increased the storage up to 2
terabytes there's a lot of people are
downloading and buying more stuff
digitally so we've been listening for
that feedback as well so when you say it
starts at $2.99 that's not the 2
terabyte version correct yeah the $2.99
is the 500 gigabyte version yeah is
there a price on the two terabyte there
my ads oh my bad yeah but it is
available to pre-order now Amazon and
other other retailers so people can find
that online and of course it depends on
what what country you're into so we
briefly talked about connect what does
Microsoft any plans for Connect going
forward yeah we're continuing you know
for me I love my connect I use it to
turn my box on and off I use it for TV
and all that we'll continue to do that
some of the things that we showed is
that we're adding Cortana capabilities
or more voice commands the voice
capabilities I think is really where
it's shining but we're still people are
using a lot for streaming people are
using it you know a lot for other
capabilities depending on different
types of apps and then you know we're
seeing some developers use it for games
but more and more it's being used for
voice and and for entertainment and I
think for an update that it was either
recent or that's upcoming you're gonna
be able to just use your microphone in
the headset to be able to control it
with Cortana you can you can use your
microphone and your headset to use
Keturah
cortana as well so it's all about
preference but if you want to record
clips you want to stream have a camera
it's actually you know that you to go
and buy a camera that's dedicated for
you know to can't record you from your
console to your to your couch it's
optimized for that so it's pretty unique
in that and that regards still has a lot
of great capabilities for people that
want that are we gonna get any you know
connect only titles any more like
connects both rivals Oh internally right
now we're focused primarily on Triple A
games we've obviously brought a lot of
Kinect games to market that you know
still working play great we've seen a
number of id developers that are doing
it but for the most part we're following
what our consumers want and listening to
them and they're saying we want more
Triple A games and so that's where we've
been focusing what if I played crackdown
by like being a monster and walking
around just smashing things like that I
will take that feedback to the team we
may be I hate to say no to any any idea
but probably won't get your hopes up on
that one so on the hardware side you
guys also introduced some new
controllers yes and so that's not quite
the same as the elite controller that we
saw a while back yeah so we have a new
program called Xbox design lab and
basically if you go to our
- Xbox comm you can go in and design
your own custom controller and we've
seen you know a lot of people do this
with aftermarket and other things but
you haven't really been able to actually
make your own custom controller and so
if I take this just for example here you
can go in and change these to all
different types of color options every
you know every you know your bumpers and
your triggers your d-pad all this can be
customized to you know a color of your
school a game you like you know whatever
kind of you want to make it's gamespot
colors you can and so you know whatever
whatever you want to customize it with
which is kind of nice and then that
controller is those controllers are the
new updated controller so they have
bluetooth built-in even if you don't get
the Xbox 1s you'll get the benefit of
having that included as well one of the
things that I loved about the the elite
controller was the ability to swap out
parts is there any thought given to
giving more parts or more customization
and that since like those different
colored buttons and yeah I mean we're
always listening and open to feedback
and you know I think we've been
innovating pretty rapidly with hardware
with the live service and so we'd love
to hear ideas and feedback I mean that
is how we ended up with this program
we'd love to see how well it does what
are people doing with it do they want
more customization the response to the
lead controller has been tremendous as a
result to that we're also doing a
limited edition Gears of War elite
controller that will be coming this
holiday as well I think you saw that we
showed it in our in our briefing so yeah
I think you know tons of opportunity to
continue to innovate in the hardware
space for sure
speaking of live you also announced
three new kind of capabilities it has
been talk a little bit uh a little bit
about those sure yeah so first I think
really we want we have everyone knows
what Xbox Live the magic of that is to
be able to play online with your friends
play with people that you have common
interests with and depending on the
types of games you play you may have
different sets of friends that you you
want to play with so we wanted to first
bring clubs to Xbox Live so you can have
those groups of players that you know
maybe people you like to play destiny
with or halo width or Forza with and
then as part of that how do you actually
go and find new friends that have common
interests and so that's the idea with
looking for group that's being added as
well or lfts many people refer to
and so now you can say hey I'm looking
for gamers that want to play this type
of game or helped me to complete this
raid or whatever it may be and you can
add those and create new groups out of
that I think those will be tremendously
popular on the service and just a great
way to find more people that are
like-minded that want to play the same
type of games and then the last piece we
announced on Xbox Live was some xbox
arena which has worked at our teams
doing around competitive gaming and
eSports and so you know we've done a lot
of stuff in competitive gaming specific
to certain titles we did the halo World
Championship this past year we're doing
things around Forza Motorsport Gears of
War Killer Instinct all big eSports
competitive titles but as we do that you
know we work with different tournament
operators and things like that it
becomes really hard for people to go
sign up and they have to kind of leave
the ecosystem but if you can sign up on
the Xbox you can track your tournaments
and what you're playing in a lot of
online ladders and stuff so a lot of
great integration there we're excited
about and we did share that working with
EA Sports on that and FIFA for example
will be one of the titles that we'll be
taking advantage of the work around Xbox
arena I think the most important part of
an arena are of course the prize pools
millions of dollars am I going to be
able to become a rich famous eSports
celebrity maybe you know it just depends
on how strong your skills are I mean I'm
really good ok well then in that case
sure yeah I mean we've got if you look
at the halo World Championship
you know the finals that we did this
past spring the winning team of four
took away a million dollars that they
split and these guys were like 19 20
year old you know so about your that's
the press yeah so so you know yes it's
possible but those you know with like a
lot of those is a lot of people just
want to play and have competitive
parents with their friends then they
kind of will go the next level where you
kind of have you know online tournaments
or online ladders and eventually you get
to the actual physical events where the
big money is and to be able to allow you
to do that you know within using Xbox
Live will do that across both Xbox one
and Windows 10 you know all the live
features we build work across our
network so it's not just specific to the
console which is great you know we've
seen a lot of great interest from our
internal studios and from third-party
partners who want to participate in that
with looking for group is there going to
be any adjustment to the ratings and
reputation system because what if you
you know get stuck with a low degree
yeah like I'm a terrible teammate I that
should probably bull you we already have
reputation built into Xbox Live so we
will be aware of that and I think yeah
that is the idea that you can one look
for people you can say that you would
like to people that would say don't want
to play with vulgarity for example you
could say I don't or hey I want to be
you know looking for foul mouthed
speaking Halo players you know there's
group for you to so you know that's the
idea is really to get people choice and
we really want to create a very
inclusive community where people feel
like they're welcomed where no matter
how good of a gamer they are or what
their interests are or you know what
their background is that they feel like
there is a place that allows gaming for
everyone and we're very very committed
to that and that's something that we've
been doing and investing with features
like this and trying to make the
community a better place to play let's
hope the games that you guys had on
stage this year there was a very
Japanese influence I mean you have Rico
with Inafune a we had Tekken 7 obviously
Final Fantasy made a surprise showing
you guys um you know is that a concerned
effort that you guys are making yeah
well you know we were all gamers we love
you know a lot of these games and you
know I wouldn't say we just said hey we
need to go put a bunch of Japanese games
on our stage but as we went to looked
out at a lot of the great games that
made sense to showcase this year across
first and third party you're right so
recore in the flow Nissan working with
him and the team at armature on that
title is a really really special thing
to go create something completely new
we've had a long-standing relationship
with Square Enix I remember when we
first put Final Fantasy on our stage and
kind of shocked III you know many many
years ago so ii love what they're doing
with Final Fantasy to be able to
showcase that working with platinum and
communist on on the team they're on
scalebound
another great title I mean we just want
to work with the greatest craters in the
world whether they're making games
exclusively for us on the third-party
side or not it did work out this year we
had a lot of great Japanese craters on
our stage we had the team from from
Tekken 7 there as well and so yeah it
was fun they were great great a great
number of craters to work with
and we know there's a number of Japanese
critters also participating in the ID at
Xbox program as well yeah I mean
Japanese gaming seems to almost be
having a resurgence button
TGS while it's kind of fallen by the
wayside and a lot of ways it it feels
like in Western circles these games are
just becoming more and more popular and
bigger all once again like the way they
would wave you used to be yeah and I
think because they are unique style
games in many cases or genres that we
might have grown up playing and that you
know we're mayor that's nostalgia
bringing back or sort of a new
generation it's allowing people to
recreate these experiences some of the
greatest game creators have always been
in Japan and so I think you know we it's
been an honor to get to work with them
over the years and having been to many
Tokyo games Joe's you're right we stun
Vail and do a lot a lot of things there
but that doesn't mean that what we're
finding is that those creations in those
games now are being played by people all
over the world and so it's just been
great to be able to partner with them on
the firts party side to go make great
exclusive games with these craters and
then of course have those partners you
know on the on the third party side as
well a good one to get would be Kojima
if you guys could just like follow
behind the stage I love that moment
where he came out with the white and he
just kept going so fast and no I've
worried Ange Rick he'll know you could
have fall through the floor I know but
there's nothing could stop that guy so I
know he's been a great partner over the
years and I've gotten to work with him
when he's been on our stage and I know
people have a deep level respect for him
and the last Metal Gear I think was a
complete masterpiece and I'm excited to
see what he's what he's creating next
I'm sure like everything it will be it
will be great let's talk another really
messing up my words today you're some of
the announcements you guys heard of this
week's a show I mean Forza horizon 3 yes
so key tousle abouit yeah well you know
over the next year we're actually gonna
bring our biggest games lineup of first
party games we've ever brought and we're
sort of reaching that sweet spot in the
generation where you know we've been
working on a number of titles and so we
kind of kicked that off with recore in
September and then we right after that
later in the month we have Forza horizon
3 which we're excited to be able to go
down to Australia really rich set of
terrain
a whole set of new vehicles we have to
cover cars for that game and again both
these titles will be Xbox play newer
titles both on Xbox one and Windows 10
then we get to the biggest exclusive
game of this year which will be Gears of
War 4 we know Gears fans gears nation is
perhaps the most passionate group of
fans I've ever met in my life and great
to work with Rod Fergusson the team of
coalition on that coming in October and
then then we kind of head through
holiday with a number of third-party
titles we're working with like like
battlefield 1 and then back to first
party with Halo Wars 2 and then you know
you know we you know in there we have
sea of thieves and we have skill bound
we have a lot of other great games
coming so whether you're looking for
racing or you want to do you know
looking for a shooter or more
action-adventure or open world pirate
fantasies we've really got a great
variety of games and I think just
finding time to play them all is gonna
be the challenge is there a push to add
all games to the play anywhere family or
is is that something that developers
decide on a ad hoc basis well we're
making the program available to them
what we have said is we wanted to be
consistency we're offering it for all
the new games that we showed at e3
they'll all be Xbox playing we're titles
this sort of really the sense of being
able to play without boundaries not
being confined by the type of device I
have or or any of that what we're seeing
is part of that we do have a number of
ID at Xbox titles that are supporting it
so we happy few that we showed in our
briefing saying people are very excited
about is coming to game preview that
will be a play anywhere title and then
cup pad is another great example of a
title that we're excited to come have
come later this year that also be it
will be a play or title and we'd love to
have third parties support the program I
think they'll see people really get
giving people more value out of the
games that they buy you you know invest
in these games you don't want to only be
able to play them just on one box or one
device and being able to give you the
freedom to do that we think you know we
were hopeful that other partners will
include it as well speaking of play
anywhere I think there was that a huge
announcement that not or not even
announcement but just Microsoft
extending an olive branch saying that
you do want your games to be playable
between anybody like Ron
League on PC on Xbox one is there still
a hope that maybe that will extend
beyond console barriers as well and and
maybe how I can play rocket league with
my friends on ps4 and Xbox one and PC
all at the same time yeah I mean art our
vision is to be able to take these games
you own and that's the idea with
bringing even Xbox Live I think we
showed it with minecraft is an example
where we're bringing Xbox Live to iOS
for bringing Xbox Live to Android so you
can play multiplayer minecraft from your
PC to your iPad to your Android phone
and allow these ecosystems that you've
always been restricted with whoo I can
play with depending on the device they
own or the ecosystem that they've chosen
and as gamers like that just you have to
have a different set of friends list and
you just you know it's just you know it
creates a barrier that really we don't
think has to be there so that's part of
the vision of this around being able to
play without boundaries rocket leaves a
great example of one where the
developers said hey we wouldn't allow
people to play across Xbox one and steam
won't oboe across other consoles we're
completely open to that and so we really
want to continue to invite you know
other partners in the space to open up
their networks as well awesome
Erin thank you so much for joining us I
hope you have a wonderful III for more
from e3 make sure you stay tuned to
Gabe's bug